Who's my good boy?
I had the perfect life.
Until one day,...
All yours, little guy.
...everything changed.
There's been a mistake!
Nina!
Ferdinand!
Now, I know when you look at me, you think "big."
You're ginormous!
I can't wait to show you to the rest of the guys.
They're gonna fertilize the yard.
It's scary.
Who are you?
I'm Uno.
I'm Dos.
And I'm Quatro.
What happened to Tres?
We do not speak of Tres.
You think someone who could fight.
I am here to select a bull.
I'll take that one.
Sucks to be you!
I am not a fighting bull!
Can you guys help me out?
This is the beautiful horsey side and that is the stinky bull side.
Have a nice day smelling terrible!
High hooves, Klaus.
High hooves, Greta.
Nina needs me.
I'm getting out of this place...
...and I'm not leaving anyone behind.
Best plan ever!
Just do exactly what we do.
Maybe don't do exactly as we do.